hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
mein grundrezept für einen total
saftigen schoko boden den tortenboden
könnt ihr für alle möglichen torten
benutzen sei es jetzt eine sahnetorte
oder ein fruchtiger torte oder aber auch
motiv torten denn dieser boden ist so
saftig und schokoladig dass er über als
sehr gut hineinpasst an zutaten
benötigen wir eigelb da gehen wir
unbedingt noch eine große prise salz
rein damit wir später die altersstruktur
schneller zerstören können außerdem
eigelb etwas milch familie extrakt
zucker butter und am trockenen zutaten
kakao und speisestärke und backpulver
zuallererst stellen wir unsere baiser
masse her und dafür geben wir das eiweiß
zusammen mit dem salz in unsere
rührschüssel wichtig ist dass die
rührschüssel sauber und fettfrei ist und
dann wird das ganze mit dem schneebesen
einmal aufgeschlagen
ihr könnt ihr sehen dass das eiweiß
schon cremig ist und etwas heller
geworden ist und an der stelle gehen wir
die hälfte unseres zuckers mit hinzu und
schlagen das dann komplett steif
so sollte eure baiser masse dann
aussehen also schön steif sein und nicht
mehr herunter fließen und dann geben wir
das in eine andere schüssel damit die
küchenmaschine wieder frei ist für die
nächsten zutaten
die schüssel braucht ja auch gar nicht
spüren den schritt spart ihr euch jetzt
einfach und dann geben wir die weiche
bzw zimmer warme butter hinein und den
restlichen zucker am besten arbeitet ihr
jetzt mit eurem rühe haken weiter wer
ein handmixer benutzt er kann auch ganz
normal die aufsätze vom schneebesen
verwenden das ist gar kein problem
und dann wird das ganze ein wenig hält
cremig gerührt
anschließend geben wir die all gebe
langsam mit hinzu und lassen es ganz
kurz unterrühren
das ganze sollte sich dann nur kurz
miteinander verbinden vergisst oder
vanille extrakt nicht das könnt ihr an
der stelle auch noch mit dazu geben wer
stattdessen weil diese zucker benutzt da
gibt es einfach ganz vorne mit hinein
dann wenn wir auch den weißen zucker mit
dem zug gibt und jetzt geht es weiter
mit den trockenen zutaten die werden
jetzt alle miteinander ganz grob
verrührt und werden anschließend in die
butter ei masse hinein gesiegt
allerdings nicht alles gleich auf einmal
ist es ganz wichtig dass sie hier in
kleinen schritten arbeitet ich gebe hier
zuallererst ein drittel meiner trockenen
zutaten hinein und lass das ganz grob
miteinander verrühren und währenddessen
geht der immer wieder ein paar stücke
oder milch mit hinzu am besten verbindet
sich das ganze wenn die milch ein wenig
lauwarm ist und nicht ganz kalt aus dem
kühlschrank dann habt ihr nicht diese
ganzen klümpchen im teig und jetzt
verfahren hier immer so weiter bis alles
aufgebraucht ist
und hier noch zwei hinweise zu den
trockenen zutaten wir verwenden
speisestärke damit der teig nach dem
backen richtig schön feinporig wird und
bacau ist ganz wichtig dass sie
tatsächlich auch den bug cacau nimmt und
nicht den trinker gau denn der ist
meistens mit ganz viel zuckerzusatz
verbunden und hat mit dem echten cacau
leider gar nichts mehr zu tun so nachdem
dann die milch und die trockenen zutaten
in den teig eingearbeitet wurden heben
wir mit ganz viel liebe und ganz
vorsichtig den eischnee unter das
erledigt ihr am besten auch in zwei bis
drei schritten denn dann könnt ihr
sicher sein dass euch dann nicht die
luft raus geht und alles schön flüssig
bleibt
so sieht der fertige teig nun aus und
kann direkt gebacken werden lasst ihn
deshalb auch nicht unnötig lange stehen
und beginnt sofort den teig zu befüllen
entweder nimmt ihr eure springform oder
euren tor bringen ich benutze heute
einen tortenring von schlage ihn
ringsherum mit backpapier entschuldigt
hier bitte die unvorteilhafte aufnahme
denn die kamera stand leider auf der
anderen seite und da bin ich ein wenig
ungeübt das in entgegengesetzter
richtung zu machen
aber ihr seht ja ungefähr wie das
funktioniert und sobald ihr euren torten
bringen dann 1 geschlagen habt könnt ihr
den teig einfüllen und backen
streich den dann noch ein wenig glatt
und back den tortenboden dann bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze im vorgeheizten
backofen für 30 minuten
und so sieht der fertige torten wohnen
dann nach dem backen aus dass sie dann
aus köln nehmen sie ihn aus dem
tortenring und dann verarbeitet ihn
gerne weiter ich habe daraus jetzt eine
hübsche haselnuss schokotorte gemacht
falls euch das video interessiert dann
klickt gerne auf das video
hinterlasst mir gern ein abo damit ihr
nichts mehr von mir verpasst und dann
sage ich bis zum nächsten mal tschüss